[Music]  Taylor Swift certainly left Glendale  Arizona shook on night one of her  reputation stadium tour the 28 year old  singer slayed in fierce costumes as she  sang her most recognizable hits  the stage was over-the-top matching the  reputation theme she had giant snakes  everywhere Taylor told the audience  quote you might be wondering why there  are so many snakes well a few years ago  someone called me a snake on social  media that's someone likely Kim  Kardashian who tweeted this in 2016  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  another highlight tailor bringing out  opening acts Charli XCX and Camila  Kibeho to help her sing shake it off  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]